je sais ça c'était le 30 avril 2020 et à
l'époque tout le monde considérait cette
théorie comme complotistes aujourd'hui
l'hypothèse d'une fuite de laboratoire
comme origine de la pandémie est prise
très au sérieux par la communauté
scientifique
voici pourquoi le premier point que les
scientifiques peinent à élucider
l incohérence géographique lorsqu'on
sait c'est que ça risque of 2 comme
virus connus le plus proche son plus
proche parent un virus du des
couvertures une chauve souris dans une
grotte à proximité de one qu'on appelle
air act et g13 on suppose à partir de là
que ces deux virus ont aumoins
d'ancêtres communs ou sont liés et que
le départ de l'épidémie
c'est des chauves souris dans cette
honte voile est l'épicentre de
l'épidémie
alors que la grotte dans laquelle a été
prévu virus se trouve à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres c'est pourquoi
l'institut de virologie de one qui
étudie les coronavirus depuis plusieurs
années est suspecté d'avoir fait fuiter
le virus il ya quand même une
coïncidence extraordinaire c'est à dire
que le foyer de l'épidémie est la ville
de l'oural où se trouve un grand centre
de virologie
le centre de virologie de vaux ain qui
est spécialisé sur ces familles de virus
den coronavirus et qui va depuis des
années
cherchez des échantillons sur les
chauves souris dans le yunnan et les
ramènent avoue anne pour étudier ces
virus et étudier comment ils peuvent
devenir infectieux pour les humains le
foyer épidémique se trouve très proche
d'eux des laboratoires qui font ces
expérimentations sur celle ci on
suspecte ces chauves-souris et cette
grotte la partie ferme en gwada parce
qu'en 2015 il y a
plusieurs mineurs qui sont tombés
malades et qui ont été contaminées sans
doute pacolli dasté peut-être pas le
sascoc 2 mais ça veut dire que
contamination entre la chauve souris et
l'homme directement est possible et ce
qui pour beaucoup plaident pour une
fille de la bo parce que les
scientifiques ont prélevé dans la grotte
les virus et après dans le laboratoire
ils sont contaminés si la théorie est
jugée peu probable par l'om est ce une
tribune cosignée par une vingtaine de
scientifiques dans la célèbre revue size
appel largement à considérer cette piste
au même moment trois documents sont
diffusées de manière anonyme sur twitter
par the seeker remettant en cause des
informations communiquées par l'institut
de virologie de waele le premier
document qui date de mai 2014 revient
sur le séquençage des ratés j13 le virus
proche du singe coop de prélever dans la
tente
on apprend par ces documents que le
virus ait raté g13 était connue du
laboratoire de one depuis au moins 2016
il avait été publié sous un autre nom
ces pratiques arrive très souvent qu'il
faut pas y voir une manoeuvre quoi que
ce soit et pourtant aucun lien entre
ce virus 2016 et le virus de 2019 est
ratée g13 avait été le second document
qui date de 2010 est fait état d'
expérimentation menée par le laboratoire
de voir prend des virus
on va les modifier une vie trop pour
essayer de comprendre comment est ce
qu'ils peuvent évoluer de manière
naturelle et mieux lutter contre on
n'apprend pas ces documents c'est que de
telles expériences ont eu lieu dans
l'est dans les laboratoires dont laurent
- laboratoire de gwan est donc gratuit
wahoo ça c'est publié l'attend est ce
qu'il ya un détail de ces expériences et
est ce qui s oublier avec le sarkozy à
ce qu'on a fait du bien de change que ça
ne nous pas objectivement n'en sais rien
ce document nous l'apprennent
enfin le dernier document qui date quant
à lui de 2019 précise que d'autres
coronavirus ont été prélevés dans cette
même droite d'autres coronavirus ont été
prélevés dans la grotte en même temps
que le a raté g13 et que ces séquençages
n'avaient pas été publiés
donc depuis lors été publiés c'est une
démarche extrêmement transparents de
faire ça c'est à dire que j'ai des
données je lui donne à tout le monde
pour que vous fassiez ce que vous voulez
pas une semaine des marges intéressantes
qui veut des chercheurs chinois bien là
pour le coup ils m'ont fait après ses
publications autre élément le wall
street journal a tout récemment affirmé
que trois chercheurs de l'institut de
virologie de one avait été hospitalisé
en 2019
à la suite de symptômes semblables à
ceux du coc u19 cette affirmation ne
fait que renforcer les soupçons à
l'égard du laboratoire la chine n'a pas
partagé les prélèvements pcr effectués
sur les cas de grippe entre octobre et
novembre 2019 un moment donné où ces cas
la grille pourrait peut-être pu être
ducobu d'alors peut-être qu'ils ont les
résultats et peut-être que c'est pas
covin dans tout cas ces résultats sont
pas partagés d'un point de vue logique
une fuite de laboratoire n'est pas
impossible et peut prendre plusieurs
formes échantillon de mal manipulé
coupure d'un chercheur morsure d'un
animal infecté ou encore des schémas le
jeter si des fuites de laboratoires se
sont déjà produites auparavant
elles n'ont toutefois pas eu de
conséquences aussi graves reste que si
aucun élément ne permet d'affirmer ou
d'infirmer cette hypothèse
l'absence de données concrètes sur le
laboratoire du wan ne fait que nourrir
les spéculations à l'égard de la chine
[Musique]